[Music]
on this Friday night rapid-response
retracing the steps of Canada's kovat 19
patients where have they been when and
who else was around it's a very
challenging virus to be able to contain
plus the plan to help workers and
businesses we are taking active
precautions as Canada ramps up testing
and the u.s. struggles the crisis
intensifies at the border between Greece
and Turkey the lie luring migrants on a
dangerous journey and remembering the
pocket rockets Cottingham the haka to
people how re rashard proved his critics
wrong and powered forward to become the
NHL's biggest champion
global national with Ghana freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are watching the spread of the new
corona virus again tonight and the
potential impact on you there are now 54
confirmed and presumptive cases in
Canada including another new case in
Alberta and two new ones in Ontario
we're also watching that cruise ship
stranded off California with 235
Canadians onboard best kits were ere
dropped to that ship by helicopter
because a man on a previous voyage died
of kovat 19 and late this afternoon the
American vice president announced 21
people on board have tested positive 19
our crew members but only 46 people of
the 303 pardon me 3,500 people on board
have been tested at this stage and right
now none of them are going anywhere back
here in Canada there is now at least one
case of community spread NBC a woman
infected with kovin 19 who has no link
to travel from a country where there's
been an outbreak be seized public health
officer says the woman's every move in
the last two weeks is now being traced
we want to know every everybody she's
been in contact with since she developed
symptoms we go by day-by-day you know
where were you here how did you get
there we do all of the details did you
go by bus did you take a private card
those are all things that are being
investigated in detail
she says that rapid detailed response
and lots of testing means the virus is
being contained in Canada of the 54
confirmed in presumptive cases here now
most are in BC and Ontario where there
are two new cases one is a man in his
20s who was in Italy the second is a
woman in her 60s who got back from Iran
both are now in self-isolation
Quebec now has a third case a
presumptive one it's a man who was
recently in France where he believes he
caught the virus from someone he knows
and there are two presumptive cases in
Alberta one was just announced a man in
his 40s in the Edmonton area he just got
back from the United States the other
case is a Calgary woman in her 50s she's
a former passenger from the Grand
Princess cruise ship she was also a
worker at a TB financial and now two of
its branches in Calgary are closed
testing here in Canada has ramped up
much faster than in the US BC and
Ontario have their own tests now and
capacity at labs is being increased the
federal government has committed 27
million dollars now to fund coronavirus
research there's also a plan to support
Canadians who were in quarantine or
self-isolation and unable to work
david aiken in Ottawa has our top story
tonight David well Donna Public Health
officials from across Canada knew this
day was going to come the first case of
a Cova 19 infection by an individual
with no history of travel it was not
unexpected certainly something that we
are prepared to deal with and the
detailed investigation the resources
that we need to put into that are
ongoing right now now the painstaking
medical detective work as BC officials
try to retrace what that patient did and
where she went for the last two weeks
there are a number of public events
there's a number of the places that
she's attended there's a workplace but
the message from the BC government the
risk remains low and detailed plans are
in place to manage a major kovat 19
related disruption that could last as
long as four months the provinces
pandemic planning covers everything from
making sure grocery stores have enough
food to rapidly moving healthcare
workers to where they are needed so we
are currently and clearly in the
containment days but it is our
responsibility in the Premier's
direction that we have been preparing
for a month from a more serious
situation as it develops B sees pandemic
plan like all provincial pandemic plans
adheres to federal guidelines set out in
the pan Canadian pandemic plan the
federal government actually provides
technical advice and support to
provinces to make those decisions but it
is the decision of the jurisdiction
meanwhile the federal government is
spending 27 million dollars for 47
different kovat 19 research projects
across the country today is a
significant investment but but it's
important to note that if additional
resources are required we are willing to
step up and provide those additional
reach
and that money will help Canadian
scientists join the international search
for a vaccine scientists here are also
trying to figure out questions like how
long does the virus persist on surfaces
or in the air and those answers could be
crucial in the fight to prevent more
kovat 19 infections in Canada Donna all
right David akin and Ottawa thanks
financial help is being planned for
Canadians who were required to self
isolate or be in quarantine and are
unable to work the federal Finance
Minister is working on that our Ottawa
bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson spoke
with Bill Morneau Mercedes what's he
saying
Donna Finance Minister Bill Morneau says
Canada has the fiscal firepower to deal
with a köppen 19 shock but still he's
preparing to shore up the Canadian
economy the Finance Minister promised
support for those who could be hardest
hit economically Canadians without paid
sick leave and industries that are
expected to bear the fallout like travel
and the service industry as well as the
oil sector we asked him just how much
the new coronavirus could hurt the
economy and how much money the
government is expecting to have to spend
on health care and those fiscal
backstops
the short answer is they don't know it
depends on how bad things will get and
therefore how much it will cost listen
to this I really can't give you a scope
the challenge really very much depends
on the depth and the duration of this
challenge around the coronavirus it also
depends on the geographic spread and so
we will we will only know that as the
facts become available
Marcedes what did more don'ts say about
how this might change the federal budget
that's going to be released we expect
sometime later this month well Donna
Morneau was cagey on when the budget
might come down but so far there's no
expectation that kovat 19 has shifted
the traditional timeline that would see
a budget in the next few weeks
the Finance Minister revealed the
government will pad the risk a judgment
adjustment provision in the budget
that's the federal government's
contingency fund a safety for unexpected
events like kovat 19 but other than that
Cova 19 spending is expected to be
outside of the federal budget rather
than included in it Donna
all right Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
Thanks and you can watch the full
interview with the finance minister on
Sunday on the West block right here on
global in the US the number of cases has
jumped past 270 now and at least 15
people have died new york city is
pleading for more test kits the Health
Department says it will quickly run out
the u.s. is now also grappling with what
to do about people onboard that cruise
ship that's off the coast of California
we just learned 21 people on board have
tested positive
Jaxson Prosecco has that story off the
coast of California more than 3,500
passengers and crew aboard the Grand
Princess are stuck in limbo 235
Canadians among those now confined to
their rooms including Ian Lancaster
Grail is from Toronto and they said
everything was canceled all the bars
were closed the restaurants were closed
we'd be having a room service tonight
the co bid 19 test kids airlifted to the
cruise ship Thursday ended up delivering
grim news 19 crew members and two
passengers on board
tested positive after five passengers
from the ship's previous sailing tested
positive and one died all passengers and
crew will be tested for the corona virus
those that need to be quarantined will
be quarantined those that require
additional medical attention will
receive it in the US Capitol president
Donald Trump signed an eight billion
dollar emergency spending bill I think
we're in great shape before touring the
Centers for Disease Control where he
downplayed the risks of coronavirus most
of those people have it'll be fine
vast majority gonna be fine and claim to
be an expert on the subject every one of
these notches said having to know so
much about
maybe I have a natural ability a botched
rollout of testing kids has left the US
with an unclear picture of how far and
wide kovat 19 has spread the number of
infected continues to grow daily so does
the death toll at this nursing home
outside Seattle where several residents
have died families are demanding answers
my mother I got a phone call this
morning that she passed it 3:30 in the
morning Pat Herrick was told her mother
Elaine died of natural causes overnight
she wonders if it wasn't the virus that
has swept through the care facility I'm
asking and lobbying to make sure she
gets tested I want her body tested and
I've been told well we don't do that you
know we just have to assume that it's
natural causes and so I'm saying it's
not okay the u.s. admits it still
doesn't have enough coronavirus test
kits to meet demand and that's a real
concern the number of deaths compared to
the number of cases identified suggests
there are far more cases out there than
currently reported Donna all right
Jackson prosecco thanks what's happening
in Italy is a sign of what this virus
can lead to if not contained Italy
recorded its highest daily death toll
from Kobe 19 today 49 people in Italy
died today of the virus and the number
of deaths in total in Italy is now 197
there are sweeping restrictions on
public gatherings there to try to limit
the spread as of tonight more than 4600
people have tested positive in Italy the
nightmare is finally over for a group of
Canadians quarantined because they were
on board the diamond princess ship in
Japan
more than a hundred former cruise ship
passengers finally made their way home
today the group spent nearly a month in
quarantine first on board the diamond
princess and then at a hotel in Cornwall
Ontario to ensure that they are virus
free
none have developed any symptoms I'm so
glad we're in Canada and I'm so glad
we're on our way your place one more
thing
more than 700 other Diamond Princess
cruise ship passengers including 50
Canadians did test positive for covin
19-6
we know you have lots of questions about
this virus we want to help answer them
you can send an email to your questions
at Global News CA an hour Jeff simple
will consult experts to find the answers
you'll also find extensive information
on our website we have a special page
dedicated entirely to the new corona
virus that's at Global News CA /
coronavirus the Toronto teenager who is
a subject of an Amber Alert yesterday is
now back with his family police found a
14 year old in what they call a
disheveled state on a property near
Brampton Ontario late last night they
say the boy was taken as retribution for
his stepbrothers drug debt police are
still searching for suspects there is an
update in the downing of that Ukraine
International Airlines jet over Iran in
January the RCMP is now on the ground
involved with Ukraine's criminal
investigation 55 Canadians were among
the 176 passengers and crew who were
killed after first denying any
responsibility Iran then admitted its
military did fire two missiles at the
plane foreign affairs minister Francois
Philippe champagne is also in Ukraine he
spoke to the President and foreign
minister he says Canada wants to bring
closure transparency and justice to the
families of the victims we are prepared
and we discussed the range of
possibility of further steps could be
taking in order to hold Iran to account
with respect to its international
obligation or the annex 13 champagne
also says he pressed the Ukraine
government for the airline to compensate
victims families soon a separate effort
is underway to get Iran to
compensate families for its role in the
downing of the airliner migrants
desperate and facing danger coming up
the growing threats they're facing at
the border between Turkey and Greece
tonight thousands of refugees and
migrants are stuck in a terrible
situation they're caught in the middle
of an ugly battle between Turkey and the
EU turkey says the millions of refugees
who fled the war in Syria are not their
problem anymore and they've opened the
border to let them leave families who
left the refugee camps in Turkey are now
living outdoors and makeshift camps
along a stretch of the border between
Turkey and Greece they're confused and
unsure about their next move and as our
Europe you're achieve crystal commencing
reports they're being met with what aid
agencies are calling violations of human
rights
[Applause]
they are the cries and screams of the
desperate people risking their lives in
hopes of reaching Europe thousands of
migrants headed towards the border
between Greece and Turkey after hearing
Turkey would no longer stop those trying
to cross a reckless and deadly lie
viburnums I'm flattered Ahmet is from
Syria the European soldiers found us and
they disconnected our motor the dinghies
motor and they pulled us towards the
Turkish part of the sea and left us
there a call to the Turkish Coast Guard
led to their rescue Hussein was pulled
from a raft Friday there are children
here and I'm very sorry for them he says
I do not feel sad for myself it doesn't
make a difference I will die in
Afghanistan or I will die here at sea
both are the same
since 2016 Turkey has been paid by the
European Union to house millions of
refugees fleeing violence in the Middle
East and Africa but last week after more
than 30 Turkish soldiers were killed in
air strikes in Syria turkey abandoned
the agreements encouraging refugees and
migrants to attempt illegal crossing
into the European Union is not an
acceptable way for Turkey to push for
further support Mozilla PN Union Greece
has responded with expanded border
patrols there are unconfirmed reports
refugees have been shot at tear gas has
been used and that Greek police have
beaten robbed and stripped refugees who
have crossed before sending them back
all we hope for now is to go back to our
country we don't want to be humiliated
and embarrassed like this we don't want
Europe or Turkey but for many Europe
remains the goal as one group is stopped
or rescued more embark on the risky
journey crystal commencing Global News
London
tracking kovat 19 how one country used
data to contain an outbreak
you are watching global national there
are critical factors that can help slow
and contain a virus like Ovid 19 a fast
response testing and public information
are key in Taiwan a digital database
that's tracks its citizens through their
cell phones has helped defy the odds and
keep infection rates there down
despite Taiwan being very close to the
outbreaks epicenter here's Heather your
ex west using AI this Canadian company
knew the kovat 19 outbreak was coming
weeks before the rest of the world now
it's using another data set to determine
what happens next
monitoring the movement of 400 million
mobile devices we have to be leveraging
those tools to stay a step ahead it's
something Taiwan has had success with
located just off mainland China many
expected Taiwan to have a high number of
covert 19 cases but weeks into the
epidemic only a few dozen in Taiwan have
become sick hit out-perform is expected
you know outcomes by a lot in the early
days of the outbreak the country used
its National Health Insurance database
and its customs and immigration database
to start creating big data it could use
to track the virus if a person went to a
clinic or doctor's office that
information would generate alerts based
on the patient's symptoms and travel
history at the borders those considered
low-risk were sent a pass by a text
message allowing them entry anyone
considered high-risk was put into
quarantine at home tracked using their
mobile phones to make sure they stayed
there China and South Korea have been
using data to track over 19 to do
location that is considered extremely
sensitive because it can identify for
the government without a warrant they
cannot get access to it the telecom
mission communications companies are not
I cannot sell it so in China they don't
have those restrictions but there could
be a way that countries like Canada
could harness the power of this 21st
century tool without putting personal
privacy at risk blue dots mobile device
information is anonymous the information
focuses on aggregate trends without
singling out individuals still the
company says not
governments are interested in leveraging
data this way in fact the Canadian
company is mostly working with countries
other than the one it calls home Heather
your ex west global news Calgary from
little brother to huge hockey star next
the legacy of a Lurie the pocket rocket
Rashard
there are hockey legends and then
there's re Rashard he spent his entire
NHL career with the Montreal Canadiens
and tonight his legion of fans are
paying tribute to him Rashard died today
at the age of 84 he began as the little
brother of hockey hero Maurice the
Rocket Rashard by the time he hung up
his skates re Rashard had hoisted the
Stanley Cup more times than any other
hockey player ever has Mike Armstrong
has his story
[Applause]
he grew up watching his big brother
their father would take him to games
the rocket was already a superstar
stepping out of that shadow would be
hard although their father may have
helped people who stepped out to my
father Nancy and Maurice he's a great
hockey player what he used to say all
the time he said wait is that I got
another one little Renner is that these
would be much better than Morris the
rocket was a grizzled veteran in 1955
literally one of the oldest players in
the league when he was joined by his
fresh-faced little brother we had
similar eyes a bigger smile and that
massive shadow to step out her hockey's
greatest goalscorer at the age of 34 as
dangerous as ever on a lion with Dickie
Moore on the left and the Rockets kid
brother pocket rocket or Ivysaur who
made the big team although he was still
out double for junior hockey there are
those recharge the game
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
now many thought re Rashard was a
publicity stunt he was too young and too
small he just had that big family name
even coached Oh Blake would say he never
expected to keep re around that first
year LaRocca games controllable that
year ended with a Stanley Cup a Montreal
break away with the littlest rocket
passing two more out through the biggest
rocket and the time the brothers would
win five championships in a row before
Maurice retired
Dalida shot but Ari was just getting
started
this is him scoring the Cup winning goal
in 1966 in aa play and this is him
scoring the Cup winning goal in 1971 re
Rashard would never score as many goals
as his brother but he was a better
all-around player re also played more
games scored more points and 1 more cups
11 - the Rockets eight by the time he
retired in 1975 he was a legend and the
franchise with so many greats names like
Beliveau Harvey Lafleur plonked Maroons
and of course the rocket it is his
little brother who's often called the
team's most valuable player of all time
[Laughter]
we would often say he was just in the
right place at the right time just one
part of great teams but you can pretty
much just write that off as one of those
things a great leader would say that is
global national for this Friday I'm
done' freezin tonight sir Canada is bath
Ontario we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to us and thanks for
watching
Robin Gale will be here at the anchor
desk over the weekend and I will see you
back here on Monday
lovely weekend bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]